[Music]
I'm gonna get your vitamin C pill
you cannot get sick okay babe hey man
are you sure you're good oh dude I'm
sorry okay Tate don't worry
seriously can you crank on the neck by
Nick Fury probably the coolest thing
that ever happened to me anyway and it's
pretty hard
yeah I'm just happy I don't have to go
to prom seriously knows we're going to
Prague huh what what yeah to her company
called they upgraded us you should have
heard me on the phone with him I really
gave him he'll hold art was crying look
at our upgraded ride pitiful what's
going on I think Nick Fury just hijacked
their summer vacation I'm Herrington to
the kids
okay awesome yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gillich our flash mob is he boring the
big abs cruising through the Alps of my
private driver Dimitri
[Music]
for the next Tony Stark I trust you say
Edith
stand by for retinol and biometric scan
retinol and biometric stand accepted
hello hello Peter I am Edith
Tony Stark's augmented reality security
and defense system so he made you for me
no but you have access to all of Tony's
protocols cool would you like to see
what I can do
[Music]
edith stands for even dead I'm the hero
Tony loved his acronyms yeah he did
I have access to the entire Stark global
security network including multiple
defense satellites as well as backdoors
to all major telecommunication networks
[Music]
is MJ texting no don't look at it
elevated that's that's wrong that's
wrong
Tom volunteer aka spider-man you now
have access to a ton of special features
we did this 100-foot swing which was
awesome no one commits the physicality
like he does he is incredible
[Music]
he's laughing no we got it I got this
[Music]